un temblor de magnitud 5,6 sobre la
escala de richter hasta los rascacielos
de yakarta la capital de Indonesia se
vieron sacudidos por el sismo este lunes
cuyo epicentro se situó a 10 kilómetros
de profundidad en Sant Jude una urbe de
la isla de Java occidental la región más
poblada del país por el momento las
autoridades reportaron más de un
centenar de víctimas mortales y más de
700 heridos
muchas casas han sido destruidas en los
pueblos y necesitamos equipos pesados
para ello y muchas carreteras han sido
cortadas todavía estamos recopilando
datos al respecto
[Risas]
3000 personas tuvieron que ser evacuadas
y un millar de casa resultaron dañadas
los trabajadores de emergencia tuvieron
que atender a los heridos en camillas
fuera de los principales hospitales en
Terrazas y parqueaderos
todo nuestro personal médico incluidos
los que están en días libres y fuera de
turno ha entrado en servicio para la
medicina tenemos suficiente porque
recibimos el apoyo de la agencia de
salud local solo Esperamos que no haya
más réplicas
según la agencia meteorológica y
geofísica en las dos horas posteriores
al terremoto se registraron 25
réplicas mientras las autoridades
trabajan para determinar la magnitud de
los daños causados hay preocupación por
posibles deslizamientos de tierra en
caso de